je vais demander à Raymond et Géraldine
de tuer
switch
on va faire on va faire un dernier tu
peux rester
voilà très bien non non non tu peux
rester là-bas
[Applaudissements]
c'est dans l'ordre de mes amis ouais
merci
allez-y s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît est-ce qu'on peut
installer une aura gentiment s'il vous
plaît merci
on l'embrasse d'ailleurs et non voilà
oui décalez-vous encore madame en rouge
je vais je fais de mes plus grands amis
à ceux avec qui je le moindre affinité
et vous adorez Gilles alors attendez non
juste vous vous madame vous venez là à
la place
merci merci merci
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on va sortir
[Musique]
c'est bon
c'est bon ça c'est réglé c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
je mets tous mes amis là-bas
madame non allez dans le public merci
les gars
c'est parfait OK
[Applaudissements]
et là voilà là voilà j'ai tous mes amis
sympa c'est génial c'est génial
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai ça c'est une émission ça
c'est l'émission voilà je sois un peu là
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous
bonsoir à tous merci d'être avec nous
il est 18h47 c'est le 6 à 7 hein bien
entendu Bernard Montiel vient de le
présenter Bernard Montiel qui est déjà
loin il est sur l'autoroute puisque
il est parti comme une flèche alors
merci d'être là tous mes amis de
l'émission merci merci Mokhtar merci
comment est-ce qu'on peut donner un
micro à la lame c'est pas trop vous
demander merci Arthur si tu peux j'adore
excuse-moi ça tu t'appelles Arthur ça te
dérange je t'appelle Nagui
c'est possible de trouver un micro
Rachid
parle bien dans le micro tu fais partie
tu fais partie de l'équipe maintenant
voilà en fait apparemment tu es DJ ici
merci merci d'être là alors les chéris
on est on est on est quel jour on est
mercredi c'est la journée des enfants
justement si vous vous étiez vous
redevenez des enfants qu'est-ce qui vous
manque quand vous étiez
les extincteurs dans la classe tout ça
ça me manque toi aussi tu l'as fait un
micro pour toi Mélissa merci tu l'as
fait tu l'as fait toi vider des
extincteurs évidemment ah ouais en
permanence tu manges beaucoup à la
cantine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'étais le référent le référence talien
tu mesurais combien en CM2 comme ça
Enora merci d'être là ma chérie
avec moi peut-être peut-être sur C8 et
oui ça c'est un scoop ouais on ne dit
pas que des conneries oui alors madame
bonsoir alors vous venez dans le public
de TPMP pourquoi vous aimez qui vous
préférez comme chroniqueur j'aime
beaucoup cette émission j'ai mes petits
préférés
[Applaudissements]
je peux le dire
les choses est-ce que vous voulez pas
nous faire une danse avec Mokhtar
[Applaudissements]
allez madame vas-y regarde là on va
mettre la musique
[Applaudissements]
on dirait des poupées russes
on ne sait pas qui rentre donc c'est fou
c'est fou je rigole c'est vrai
pas quoi moi j'ai un truc de fou quoi
c'est incroyable hein franchement alors
on sent la peur est-ce que vous voulez
est-ce que vous voulez vous mettre bien
au centre de la piste Mokhtar
allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez
[Applaudissements]
attends attends
le réalisateur quand je dis une famille
en or pourquoi vous prenez cette caméra
voilà c'est ça faites-moi des sons de
réalisateur vous faites le moins bien
non mais sans rigoler je suis obligé de
réaliser l'émission ne me dites pas
qu'il y a un truc qui marche pas le
mélangeur au meilleur que n'importe quoi
joli voyez bien voilà ça c'est un plan
de Pamiers en or par contre Delphine tu
rejoins le groupe tu es très loin sur le
plan là vas-y t'inquiète pas mets-toi à
côté de Raymond il arrivera rien de mal
Raymond et bien sûr routier
avec toute la route qu'il fait il a pas
envie on peut le faire n'importe quoi
pendant l'émission
C'est très bien je parle à demain très
sympathique très bien j'adore cette
émission
je suis un peu tendu
[Applaudissements]
vous avez des ondes dans vos mains Cyril
qu'est-ce que tu dis vous avez des ondes
dans vos mains non non c'est mon
portable
c'est vrai qu'on est une famille TPMP on
parlait d'une famille en or et c'est
vrai que alors on aime tout le monde
comment ça va Matthieu Mathieu qui a
rejoint
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je vois que tu es venu avec vous vous
étiez
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tellement
vous avez acheté le débardeur à mykono
par contre alors est très beau vous à
côté alors franchement Mathieu il est
pas mal il est beau mais là je ne suis
pas à ma place
dans la lumière c'est pas dans le peuple
et même si je les aime champagne
tu es très bien là-bas oui Mathieu et
Gilles et moi on fait pas partie de la
famille du coup bien sûr alors
pas du tout
pas du tout là on est la semaine vous
venez le weekend
venez nous alors Géraldine tu peux venir
[Applaudissements]
voilà Géraldine voilà il y en a qui a
toujours le relou dans la famille
préférée Gégé tu le sais hein excuse-moi
qu'est-ce que tu fais là
ton mec qui est pas bien là
[Applaudissements]
je ne connais pas comment vous appelez
monsieur
qui est très très heureux de dire son
prénom direct
Serge on dirait un gars qui a fait les
Marseillais mais il y a 200 ans
c'est un gars c'est un ancien ancien
ancien des Marseillais tu vois bah il a
fait les Ch'tis à Miami il a tout fait
des Ch'tis
est-ce que vous voulez pas faire une
petite danse avec Mathieu
[Applaudissements]
on va on va imaginer qu'on est au Rambo
à Nicolas et maintenant on se calme ça
sa femme est là
[Rires]
bien tu vas bien
mais pas du tout tu vois bien que la CD
L5
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
merci
non non vraiment vraiment vraiment les
deux les deux ils vivent en débardeur
j'aime beaucoup
Serge est-ce qu'il veut danser est-ce
que tu as envie de danser avec Mathieu
non mais non mais non non non
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
la première
c'est toi mon préféré
[Applaudissements]
avec plaisir
attention Serge Serge je t'aime beaucoup
mais je vois en enlever ton slip
tu vas te faire je t'adore trop vite
non monsieur de brûler les étangs
donc on va y aller on va faire une
petite danse hein on va on va se
rapprocher et je suis dans 10 minutes on
se plaint bouffera le cul mais bon
[Applaudissements]
les gars juste je voudrais dire un truc
et Serge je te dis à toi on a quand même
oublié Benjamin Castaldi et Gilbert
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on me dit on me dit malheureusement que
Gilles Verdez a eu un petit souci ah oui
il s'est coincé une couille dans une
porte
on va voir ce qu'on est en train de
faire on est en train de lui mettre de
l'hexomedine
pas pour l'instant Serge tu vas te
rester tu vas rester là tu te mets là
qu'est-ce qui se passe
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
il est très beau Raphaël on dirait on
dirait Guillaume
c'est vraiment mais c'est l'enfant
mais c'est vrai c'est un truc de ouf on
dirait ton frère c'est un truc de fou
hein c'est dingue regardez regardez elle
est deux vous allez bien ensemble
quand je vois comme ça je me dis c'est
dingue franchement vous êtes magnifique
tous j'adore non mais c'est vrai
franchement j'adore parce que c'est tout
ce que j'aime il y a tout le monde est
représenté voilà les gens voilà
non mais c'est vrai voilà des gens qui
voilà qui arrive des gens qui repartent
les chéris j'ai envie ce soir vraiment
qu'on soit tous unis main dans la main
parce que ça c'est ça c'est la France
Enora tu peux y aller
[Applaudissements]
tu te mets là tu te mets par là à côté
de Daniel vas-y c'est pas grave les deux
pas mal hein
c'est votre mari oui
est-ce que vous vous êtes connus en
débardeur tous les deux
[Applaudissements]
ans quoi c'est tout
on était jeune
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
donc vous êtes donc vous avez 22 ans non
vous l'avez connu quel âge je l'ai connu
avec 14 ans et alors j'ai perdu de vue
et on s'est repris il y a 6 ans alors
zombie c'est quoi votre prénom Sylvie
Sylvie je te le dis j'ai eu un coup de
cœur pour Serge ah bien je pense que
c'est un homme d'une gentillesse
incroyable vraiment je te le dis moi je
vois là j'ai un coup de cœur pour toi
Serge je te le dis non mais vraiment je
te le dis alors si toi tu veux que je te
prête 500000 €.
moi je veux bien moi
vous êtes sur l'achat d'une maison non
pas encore pas encore d'accord bah vous
venez de vous marier
ça va hein tu vois ou pas tu vois et toi
tu as pas un mec qui était à l'école je
fais appel alors si il y a encore des
gens vivants
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
de Daniel s'il y a des gens encore
vivants qui étaient dans sa classe même
des gens morts qui bougent encore
n'hésitez pas à nous contacter bien
entendu et Daniel oui oui Moka oui
[Applaudissements]
comment vous appelez Salim Salim salut
Salim Salim tu es célibataire non ah
merde
bonjour
c'est le même style que Daniel
les mecs
ça part en couille
[Applaudissements]
on était sur une séquence pleine d'amour
les gars on se régalait Salim était là
il m'a dit c'est ma femme
Daniel elle est gentil tu as raison et
tu n'as rien oui
bonsoir
tu en es où retourne-toi tu t'en fous
regarde la caméra tu tu en es où
sentimentalement tout va bien
[Rires]
donc pour l'instant c'est toujours ta
femme pour l'instant d'accord
écoute donc tu es tu mets une option sur
Daniel au cas où
tu mets une option d'accord
[Applaudissements]
comment ça va toi mon chéri comment tu
t'appelles
oh là là je suis ici là il est nul tu
fais combien de temps
ça va faire 9 mois bientôt tu as pas
l'air sure de toi
elle est où elle est où ta meuf elle est
belle elle est ma vie
comment tu t'appelles
franchement j'en ai connu et c'est beau
hein regardez et toi aussi toi tu
attends tu vas bien tu as brisé une
famille quand même en 2 minutes quand
même cette connerie et vous êtes connu
comment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il va trop loin
qui est votre chroniqueur préféré moi
c'est Gilles
est très drôle
qui est toujours ah il est là bah viens
j'y vais à la fin bisous
[Applaudissements]
cette virilité quand il court alors là
tu peux me dire ça les Américains nous
le voleront pas tu peux revenir en quoi
regardez cette virilité
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez fait vous avez fait
quoi pendant les vacances
j'ai envie
de vous offrir un petit séjour
est-ce qu'on peut me faire descendre
vous montez ou venir la personne des
partenariats
ou bien Lionel Stan directeur général
d'âge de zoo pour voir si on a de
l'oseille ou bien une personne qui
travaille encore ici
puisque il est 19h08 tu rappelles qu'on
est en direct et que les personnes s'en
vont comme des petits pains au sein de
la société donc voilà si quelqu'un peut
venir le plus rapidement possible bien
entendu Serge j'ai envie de t'offrir un
petit weekend un petit séjour avec ta
femme
merci ce que je te kiffe
ça me fait plaisir on attend voilà qui
arrive qui arrive merci vous qu'est-ce
que vous avez fait cet été
je vais vous offrir un séjour
[Applaudissements]
Mélissa
viens me voir ça va mamie ça va tu es
comment toi tu es célibataire
[Rires]
son mari excuse-moi je crois que tu as
contrôle d'histoire-géo demain
quand même contrôle distj demain à 8h30
mon gars
je vais vous offrir à vous également un
séjour comment tu t'appelles
[Applaudissements]
événement c'est pour quand c'est pour
bientôt un mois je serai là
[Applaudissements]
comme ça et c'est une fille ou un garçon
on sait ou pas une fille vous allez
l'appeler comment
Géraldine maillet
je vous offre un séjour je vous offre un
séjour
[Applaudissements]
attendez j'ai Adèle des partenariats
Adèle Hades oui le bébé
on a quoi là en stock là dis-moi on a
pas un truc avec grosse B aussi j'aime
bien ça
je vais en parler juste après on m'a
jamais parlé sur tout
alors mon Adèle et qu'est-ce qu'on a
comme séjour là
combien de personnes non il y a trois
couples plus je vais au 4 tu es là tu
veux y aller avec ton ex-femme
4 5 6 couples il y a un jetons aussi
avec son fils
merci couple ou pas Enora bien sûr
tu vas partir t'inquiète pas
mais non mais cinq jours et tu me mets
pour Enora tu as des lasagnes bolognaise
[Applaudissements]
regarde ce que tu as pour pour un
smartphone un smartphone une Smart un
smartphone un smartphone
cinq séjours en week-end week-end séjour
tout compris pour des amis c'est un
couple et tu me mets pour moi
ce que tu sais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
exactement
rose
bébé merci je t'aime mon chéri je t'aime
merci
[Applaudissements]